seventy thousand years ago our ancestors
were insignificant animals the most
important thing to know about
prehistoric humans is that they were
unimportant their impact on the world
was not much greater than that of
jellyfish or fireflies or woodpeckers
today in contrast we control this planet
and the question is
how did we come from there to here
how did we turn ourselves from
insignificant apes minding their own
business in a corner of africa into the
rulers of planet earth
usually we look for the difference
between us and all the other animals on
the individual level we want to believe
i want to believe that there is
something special about me
about my body about my brain that makes
me so superior to a dog or a pig or a
chimpanzee
but the truth is that on the individual
level i am embarrassingly similar to a
chimpanzee and if you take me in a
chimpanzee and put us together on some
lonely island and we had to struggle for
survival to see who survives better i
would definitely place my bets on the
chimpanzee
not on myself
and this is not something wrong with me
personally
i guess if they took almost any one of
you and placed you alone with a
chimpanzee on some island the chimpanzee
would do much better
the real difference between humans and
all other animals is not on the
individual level it's on the collective
level
humans control the planet because they
are the only animals that can cooperate
both flexibly and in very large numbers
now there are other animals like the
social insects the bees the ants that
can cooperate in large numbers but they
don't do so flexibly their cooperation
is very rigid there is basically just
one way in which a beehive can function
and if there is a new opportunity or a
new danger the bees cannot reinvent the
social system overnight they cannot for
example execute the queen and establish
a republic of bees or a communist
dictatorship of worker bees
other animals like the social mammals
the wolves the elephants the dolphins
the chimpanzees
they can cooperate much more flexibly
but they do so only in small numbers
because cooperation among chimpanzees is
based on intimate knowledge one of the
other if i'm a chimpanzee and you're a
chimpanzee and i want to cooperate with
you i need to know you personally what
kind of chimpanzee are you are you a
nice chimpanzee are you an evil
chimpanzee are you trustworthy if i
don't know you how can i cooperate with
you
the only animals that can combine the
two abilities together and cooperate
both flexibly and still do so in very
large numbers is us homo sapiens
one versus one
or even ten versus ten chimpanzees might
be better than us
but if you beat one thousand humans
against one thousand chimpanzees the
humans will win easily for the simple
reason that a thousand chimpanzees
cannot cooperate at all
and if you now try to cram 100 000
chimpanzees into oxford street or into
wembley stadium or gentleman square of
the vatican you will get chaos complete
chaos just imagine wembley stadium with
a hundred thousand chimpanzees complete
madness
in contrast humans normally gather there
in tens of thousands and what we get is
not chaos usually what we get is
extremely sophisticated and effective
networks of cooperation
all the huge achievements of humankind
throughout history whether it's building
the pyramids or flying to the moon have
been based not on individual abilities
but on this ability to cooperate
flexibly in large numbers
think even about this very talk that i'm
giving now i'm standing here in front of
an audience of about 300 or 400 people
most of you are complete strangers to me
similarly i don't really know the people
all the people who have organized and
worked on this event
i don't know the pilot and the crew
members of the plane that brought me
over here yesterday to london
i don't know the people who invented and
manufactured this microphone and these
cameras which are recording what i'm
saying
i don't know the people who wrote all
the books and articles that i've read in
preparation for this talk
and i certainly don't know all the
people who might be watching this talk
over the internet somewhere in buenos
aires or in new delhi
nevertheless even though we don't know
each other we can work together to
create this global exchange of ideas
this is something chimpanzees cannot do
they communicate of course but you will
never catch a chimpanzee traveling to
some distant chimpanzee band to give
them a talk about bananas or about
elephants or anything else that might
interest chimpanzees
now cooperation is of course not always
nice
all the horrible things humans have been
doing throughout history and we have
been doing some very horrible things all
those things are also based on
large-scale cooperation prisons are a
system of cooperation slaughterhouses
are a system of cooperation
concentration camps are a system of
cooperation chimpanzees don't have
slaughterhouses and prisons and
concentration camps
now supposed i've managed to convince
you perhaps that yes we control the
world because we can cooperate flexibly
in large numbers
the next question that immediately
arises in the mind of inquisitive
listener
is how exactly do we do it what enables
us alone of all the animals to cooperate
in such a way
the answer is our imagination
we can cooperate flexibly with countless
numbers of strangers because we alone of
all the animals on the planet can create
and believe
fictions fictional stories
and as long as everybody believes in the
same fiction
everybody obeys and follows the same
rules the same norms the same values
all other animals use their
communication system only to describe
reality
a chimpanzee may say look there is a
lion let's run away oh look there is a
banana tree over there let's go and get
bananas
humans in contrast use their language
not merely to describe reality but also
to create new realities fictional
realities a human can say look there is
a god above the clouds and if you don't
do what i tell you to do after you die
god will punish you and send you to hell
and if you all believe these stories
that i have invented then you will
follow the same norms and laws and
values and you can cooperate
this is something only humans can do
you can never convince a chimpanzee to
give you a banana by promising him that
after you die you'll go to chimpanzee
heaven
and you'll receive lots and lots of
bananas for your good deeds so now give
me this banana no chimpanzee will ever
believe such a story only humans believe
such stories which is why we control the
world whereas the chimpanzees are locked
up in zoos and research laboratories
now you may find it acceptable that yes
in the religious field humans cooperate
by believing in the same fictions
millions of people come together to
build a cathedral or a mosque or fight
on a crusade or a jihad because they all
believe in the same stories about god
and heaven and hell
but what i want to emphasize is that
exactly the same mechanism
underlies all other forms of mass scale
human cooperation not only in the
religious field
take for example the legal field
most legal systems today in the world
are based on a belief
in human rights
but what are human rights
human rights just like god in heaven are
just a story that we've invented they
are not an objective reality they are
not some biological fact about homo
sapiens
take a human being cut him open look
inside
you will find the heart the kidneys
neurons hormones dna but you won't find
any rights
the only place you find rights is in the
stories that we have invented and spread
around over the last few centuries they
may be
very positive stories
very good stories but they are still
just fictional stories that we've
invented
the same is true of the political field
the most important factors in modern
politics are states and nations but what
are states and nations they are not an
objective reality a mountain is an
objective reality you can see it you can
touch it you can even smell it
but a nation or a state like israel or
iran or france or germany this is just a
story that we've invented and became
extremely attached to
the same is true of the economic field
the most important actors today in the
global economy are companies and
corporations
many of you perhaps work for the
cooperation like google or toyota or
mcdonald's what exactly are these things
they are what lawyers call
legal fictions
they are stories invented and maintained
by the powerful wizards we call lawyers
and
what do corporations do all day
mostly they try to make money yet what
is money again money is not an objective
reality it has no objective value
take this green piece of paper the
dollar bill look at it it has no value
you cannot eat it you cannot drink it
you cannot wear it
but then come along these master
storytellers the big bankers the finance
ministers the prime ministers and they
tell us a very convincing story look you
see this green piece of paper it is
actually worth 10 bananas
and if i believe it and you believe it
and everybody believes it it actually
works i can take this worthless piece of
paper go to the supermarket give it to a
complete stranger whom i've never met
before and get in exchange real bananas
which i can actually eat
this is something amazing you can never
do it with chimpanzees
chimpanzees trade of course yes you give
me a coconut i'll give you a banana that
can work
but
you give me a worthless piece of paper
and you expect me to give you a banana
no way what do you think i am a human
money in fact is the most successful
story ever invented and told by humans
because it is the only story everybody
believes
not everybody believes in god
not everybody believes in human rights
not everybody believes in nationalism
but everybody believes in money and in
the dollar bill
take even osama bin laden he hated
american politics an american religion
and american culture but they had no
objection to american dollars he was
quite fond of them actually
to conclude then
we humans control the world
because we live in a dual reality
all other animals live in an objective
reality
their reality consists of objective
entities like rivers and trees and lions
and elephants
we humans we also live in an objective
reality in our world too there are
rivers and trees and lions and elephants
but over the centuries we have
constructed on top of this objective
reality a second layer of fictional
reality a reality made of fictional
entities like nations like gods like
money like corporations
and what is amazing
that as history unfolded
this fictional reality became more and
more powerful
so that today the most powerful forces
in the world are these fictional
entities
today the very survival of rivers and
trees and lions and elephants
depends on the decisions and wishes of
fictional entities like the united
states like google like the world bank
entities that exist
only in our own imagination
thank you
wow
you have a new book out after sapiens
who wrote another one and uh it's out in
hebrew but not yet to translate it into
i'm working on the translation as
okay and you in in the book if i
understand it you argue that actually
the amazing breakthrough that uh
we are experiencing right now not only
will potentially make our life better
but uh
they will create an equal to new classes
and new class struggles just as the
industrial revolution did can you
elaborate for us
yes in the industrial revolution we saw
the
creation of a new class of the urban
proletariat and much of the political
and social history of the last 200 years
involved what to do with this class and
the new problems and opportunities
now we see the creation of a new massive
class of useless people
as
computers become better and better in
more and more fields there is a distinct
possibility that computers will
outperform us in most tasks and will
make humans redundant and then the big
political and economic question of the
21st century will be what do we need
humans for or at least what do we need
so many humans for do you have an answer
in the book
um at present the best guess we have is
keep them happy with drugs and computer
games
but this doesn't sound like a very
appealing future
okay so we're basically saying in the
book and now that for all the discussion
about you know the growing evidence of
significant economic inequality we are
just kind of at the beginning of the
process
again it's not a prophecy it's
seeing all kinds of possibilities before
us one possibility is this creation of a
new massive class of useless people
another possibility is the division of
humankind into different biological
costs with the rich being upgraded into
virtual gods and the poor being degraded
to this level of of useless useless
people i feel there is another ted talk
coming up in a year too thank you for
making the trip thank you thanks